toilet breaks down who do you call so i  i fix my own car i can i can do it i'm  most mechanics your power your power  supply who runs it who runs the  infrastructure of society men or women  oh at the moment men obviously yeah  because because of  patriarchy wait do i need a man no this  is i'm obsessed with being a woman in a  male-dominated industry i do all of my  own carpentry  right but but regardless of that like  you agree that men run the  infrastructure so therefore at the  moment yeah men run the world so they we  need men  yeah yeah on a wider scale yes a wider  scale on a personal scale no because you  don't need a man to provide for you  right you can earn all right  but we need men to run the industries  that keep us alive and well